There are some stars who've showed up onscreen
for just a handful of minutes, yet still managed
to snag acting's most prestigious prize.
Often, these are supporting actors who steal
the spotlight in a few seconds, but at least
one leading man won his Best Actor award for
barely any scenes at all.
Some popular films stand the test of time,
while others fade into obscurity.
Sadly, Shampoo falls into the latter category.
This 1975 satire tells the story of a hairdresser,
played by Warren Beatty, who's juggling multiple
women while trying to open his own salon.
The movie was a major hit at the time, raking
in nearly $50 million at the box office.
It also impressed the members of the Academy,
as it nabbed four Oscar nominations.
However, the only one to go home with the
gold was Lee Grant, an actress who was on
screen for just around 18 minutes.
Grant won the Oscar for playing Felicia, a
lonely housewife who's trying to keep her
adulterous husband's attention while conducting
her own affair with Beatty.
Felicia is whiny, wealthy, well-dressed, and
simultaneously lustful and lonely.
Even though she's only onscreen for about
17 percent of the film, it was enough to impress
the Academy.
This was Grant's third shot at Oscar gold,
after getting nominations for Detective Story
and The Landlord, and she finally won the
prize that night.
Sadly, despite her award-winning performance,
it seems Shampoo has been scrubbed clean out
of the pop culture consciousness.
The Silence of the Lambs isn't your typical
award-winning film, but it shattered all Oscar
expectations by becoming the first proper
horror movie to win the Best Picture Oscar.
It was released in February 1991, and 13 months
later, it somehow crushed all the more award-friendly
films released during Oscar season.
Most importantly, it's one of only three films
that have won the big five Oscars: Best Picture,
Best Director, Best Screenplay, Best Actress,
and Best Actor.
Crazier still, that Best Actor award went
to a man who was in the film for a mere 16
minutes… but every second he's onscreen
is absolutely electric.
Anthony Hopkins beat the likes of Robert De
Niro and Robin Williams to win the Oscar for
his turn as the sophisticated psychopath,
Hannibal Lecter.
Years later, people still talk about his performance
and quote some of his most iconic lines:
"I ate his liver with some fava beans and
a nice chianti."
From the moment he appears on screen, Hopkins
radiates pure evil.
While he rarely raises his voice, he commands
every scene he's in, and with his unblinking
eyes and perfect posture, he totally unnerves
audiences.
Sure, Hopkins only shows up for 14 percent
of the film, but every death-rattling, bone-chilling
moment is worth its weight in Oscar gold.
"Yeah...that was good.
Pity about poor Katherine, though.
Tick tock tick tock tick tock."
After earning a Best Actress nomination for
Rachel Getting Married, Anne Hathaway got
her second shot at Oscar gold with Les Miserables,
an epic musical set in 19th-century France.
Hathaway shows up for a mere 15 minutes in
a movie that runs nearly three hours long,
but while she only appears in nine percent
of the film, she won the Oscar for Best Supporting
Actress.
Hathaway threw herself into the part completely,
losing a shocking 25 pounds and cutting all
her hair off.
She even went so far as to study prostitution,
and hearing the sad stories of modern-day
sex workers took a major toll.
Then there's the performance itself.
Whenever Hathaway opens her mouth, she's singing
at the top of her lungs, and on top of hitting
all those crazy notes, she's also acting her
heart out.
She's desperate and lost and trying to survive.
She's angry and hyperventilating and falling
apart.
Once again, she's doing all of this while
singing, and her rendition of "I Dreamed a
Dream" is absolutely devastating.
In short, she definitely deserved that award
for breaking our hearts in just 15 short minutes.
In the '80s and early '90s, Kim Basinger found
frequent work in films like Never Say Never
Again, The Natural, and Tim Burton's Batman.
But in 1995, she took a break from acting
for a couple of years until director Curtis
Hanson tracked her down.
Hanson was adapting James Ellroy's neo-noir
novel L.A. Confidential, and he thought Basinger
would be perfect for the part of Lynne Bracken,
a hooker sex worker with a heart of gold who
also looks a lot like Hollywood legend Veronica
Lake.
Originally, Basinger wasn't interested in
the part, as she was sick of playing characters
defined by their sex appeal.
But Hanson convinced her to take the role,
and Basinger made Lynne Bracken more than
just a blonde bombshell.
Even though Basinger is only in the film for
15 minutes, she makes the most of her limited
time, sharing intimate moments with Russell
Crowe and telling off Guy Pearce with a powerful
monologue.
"I see Bud because he doesn't know how to
disguise who he is.
I see Bud for all the ways he's different
from you."
It was a standout performance that caught
the attention of the Academy and earned the
star an Oscar for Best Supporting Actress.
During the 2000s, Woody Allen kept himself
busy, directing at least one movie every single
year.
Almost all of those films have been completely
forgotten by time.
Vicky Cristina Barcelona has pretty much suffered
the same fate as the rest of Allen's films
from that era, but there is one little detail
that's saved the movie from total obscurity:
it features an Oscar-winning performance from
Penelope Cruz.
In fact, Cruz won a truckload of awards for
her turn as María Elena, the fiery and suicidal
ex-wife of a womanizing artist.
She only shows up for 15 minutes, but she
crushes it in every single one of her scenes.
Whether she's defiantly speaking Spanish,
wildly trying to shoot Javier Bardem, or making
out with Scarlett Johansson, Cruz is the star
of the show.
Even though she was up against some major
competition from the likes of Amy Adams and
Viola Davis, it should come as no surprise
that Penelope cruised to victory thanks to
those stunning moments.
Alan Arkin is one of those actors who should've
won an Oscar long before he finally did.
The man was nominated twice, and he had plenty
of other powerful performances in other films
as well.
Thankfully, Arkin got his well-deserved trophy
at the 79th Academy Awards for his performance
in Little Miss Sunshine.
In a movie filled with amazing actors, Arkin
stands out as the larger-than-life Edwin Hoover.
He's a dirty old man with a foul mouth, a
fondness for drug use, and an incredibly grumpy
disposition.
But while Arkin earns plenty of laughs with
colorful language, he also tugs on the old
heartstrings in scenes like the one when he
tells his tearful granddaughter that she'll
never be a loser so long as she tries to accomplish
her dreams.
"You know what a loser is?
A real loser is someone so afraid of not winning,
they don't even try."
Even though he's only in the film for a scant
14 minutes, he proved he was definitely a
winner when he snagged that Oscar.
1976 was an incredible year for film and an
even better one for supporting actors.
Network, Marathon Man, and Rocky all featured
powerful supporting actor performances, but
when the votes were all tallied up, the little
gold statuette actually went to Jason Robards
for his commanding turn in All the President's
Men.
Compared to his competitors, Robards' performance
as Washington Post editor Ben Bradlee is incredibly
understated.
He's a prickly perfectionist, an editor who
drives his reporters hard and callously edits
their work.
But the man's heart is in the right place.
Sure, he's brash, but he just wants a solid
story, reporting that'll withstand the scrutiny
of everybody from Joe Schmoe to the president
of the United States.
"I can't do the reporting for my reporters
which means I have to trust them.
And I hate trusting anybody."
Robards is only on screen for about 14 minutes,
but that was more than enough to impress the
Academy.
They say good things come to those who wait,
and that's especially true for Jack Palance.
The Hollywood veteran was nominated for Best
Supporting Actor in 1952 for his performance
as a murderous husband in Sudden Fear.
Sadly, Palance didn't win that year, but he
got a second chance in 1953, earning another
nomination for his work as a black-clad gunslinger
in Shane.
But once again, Palance was robbed of Oscar
glory, and he would have to wait nearly 40
more years before getting that gold.
Palance would finally get his due thanks to
his performance in City Slickers, a 1991 comedy
that follows three city dwellers who spend
a vacation at a dude ranch.
During their quest to become cowboys, they
meet a grizzled old ranch hand by the name
of Curly Washburn.
"Did you see that guy?
That's the toughest man I've ever seen in
my life."
Palance is only on screen for around 12 minutes,
but his tough-as-nails performance would nab
him that Best Supporting Actor Oscar.
"This man owes you an apology."
Judi Dench is perhaps the most British woman
who's ever lived.
Everything about her just radiates nobility.
So it's no wonder that Dench won an Oscar
for her performance as Queen Elizabeth I in
Shakespeare in Love.
Even though she's only onscreen for three
scenes, it's a role she was born to play.
Whenever she stands, every knee bows.
She's commanding and demanding.
Her humor is biting, and her words cut to
the bone.
"What do you love so much?"
"Your majesty…"
"Speak up girl, I know who I am."
But beneath that powdered, powerful exterior,
there's a woman with a love for theater and
a sympathy for our star-crossed lovers, William
Shakespeare and Viola.
Alternately hilarious and powerful, Dench
only appears in only eight minutes of the
film, but she owns all of them.
A complicated royal and a deus ex machina
rolled into one, Dench's Queen Elizabeth is
worthy of both allegiance and awards.
"I thought you were here because you had none."
In 1976, director Sidney Lumet created one
of the darkest, most brilliant satires ever
put to film: Network.
The film holds up with incredible performances,
but Beatrice Straight made Academy Award history
by winning Best Supporting Actress with just
five minutes of screen time.
Straight plays Louise, the jilted wife of
a TV executive.
When her husband confesses to having an affair
with a younger woman, Louise gives a hell-and-brimstone
sermon that no preacher will ever match.
"I'm your wife dammit, and if you can't work
up a Winter passion for me then the least
I require is respect and allegiance!"
Both embarrassed and filled with righteous
anger, she lays into her husband hard, ripping
him apart for his philandering before breaking
down and admitting how much he's hurting her.
And as icing on the acting cake, she ends
the scene actually feeling sorry for her husband,
knowing that his new affair will just leave
him feeling a lot of grief.
All in all, Straight only shows up in Network
for five minutes and 40 seconds.
To this day, no one has beaten Straight's
incredible record, and chances are good she'll
hold onto that honor for a long, long time.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.